are you going to be able to stop the
small boats well that's our objective we
couldn't have been clearer in putting it
as one of the five central Promises of
this government to stop the boat secure
our borders and bring fairness back to
our Asylum system we're going to do
everything in our power to achieve that
and ultimately it will be for the public
to decide at the next general election
whether we've succeeded or not but being
no doubt that the prime minister of the
home sector and I will do everything we
can to achieve that goal
listening to some of the language you're
using there it's your objective you're
going to do everything you can to
achieve it not saying yeah we are going
to stop the small boat we are going to
to stop the small boats and we will do
everything that we can it is a complex
challenge it would be wrong of me to
pretend otherwise that's why we're going
to pull every lever at our disposal from
the legislation that we've presented to
Parliament this week to the Diplomatic
front that the prime minister is
continuing tomorrow or Friday in in
Paris with president macron to the work
that I'm doing with the security
services and the police to toughen up
our approach Upstream to the criminal
gangs we're going to do everything
possible to resolve this are we going to
be paying the French more
well we've already given them further
funding in the arrangement that we
reached at the end of last year and that
was for work that is now happening we're
seeing are we going to give them more
money well you'll have to wait and see
what the Prime Minister agrees with
president macron at the end of the week
but not ruling it out what we're seeking
to achieve is a number of things one of
which is more police officers French
officers on the beaches and the
hinterland of them in northern France so
they would intercept as many of these
boats as possible and the moment the
French are actually intercepting 50 of
them so that's meaningful to us the more
we can do on that front the better and
we also want our intelligence services
to be cooperating and working together
in real time so that when we learn about
what the criminal gangs are doing we get
that information to our French
counterparts and they take action we're
very clear-eyed about how tough this is
we need to be robust against these
criminal gangs because they're amongst
the most organized and evil people in
society today I just want to have a look
at some of the practicalities of this
well so you're saying that if you enter
the UK illegally not three legal routes
then you will not be able to claim
Asylum so what then happens to those
people like you could I understand you
we've got return agreements with certain
countries like Albania but there's lots
of other countries where many many
people come from that we don't and like
Syria for example 4 500 people arriving
from Syria last year you're not going to
just pick up the phone to Assad are you
well that's the reason why we need safe
third countries like Rwanda and we want
to get that Arrangement up and running
as soon as possible I was very pleased
to see at the end of last year that the
high court upheld it as a legal policy
it's being appealed at the moment it
will be before the court of appeal next
month assuming that that has a similar
positive judgment for the government
then will operationalize that as quickly
as we can let's get real on Rwanda right
45 000 people your figures um crossing
the channel last year in small boats
Rwanda initially agrees to take 200
people
period that's not correct I mean not the
only journalists who have said that but
the scheme with Iran is uncapped so the
Rwandan government and we've spoken to
them again this week Rashid soon I spoke
to Paul kagami his opposite number
they're willing to take as many people
as is required completely unlimited
unlimited arrangement we don't think
it's going to take anything like that
that's your estimate then it's the
number of people who you're expecting to
send to Rwanda well we'll take as many
we'll set as many people as is required
no because what we expect will happen is
that this will break once and for all
the people Smugglers have you done it
we've worked through scenarios and the
Australian uh experience shows is that
within weeks once it's clear that you
will not spend time in the UK or in
Australia in that case people will stop
making the journey so what I expect to
see is that we will operationalize this
policy a very large number people will
need to go there in the initial weeks
and months
well it depends how many people are
crossing the channel at that time but if
it requires thousands of people to be
sent to Rwanda then we will send
thousands of people since that you
launched the scheme in April well well
none because it's been caught that's my
point right that makes that makes the
point pretty well though doesn't it you
said that there are complex issues I
don't think it does because the legal
ramifications of this which are going to
be extensive well the good news is stuck
on the bright side it's obvious that the
court of appeal is hearing the case and
we expect that it will come to a similar
judgment to the high court which said
that the policy was lawful if that's the
case then we should be able to get this
policy up and running quite quickly and
we will remove as many people as is
required to have the deterrent effect
and then I think you'll start to see the
numbers crossing the channel fall very
rapidly and that's the key thing here
because we want deterrence to be
suffused throughout our approach so that
we break the model of the people
smuggling gangs we don't want people to
be risking their lives spending their
life savings at the best of these evil
criminals we want to bring order and
fairness back to the Asylum system what
are you going to do with children
well what we've said is that if you come
with your family then you will be part
of the scheme so you'll be detained as a
family group and you will then be
removed either to your home country if
it's safe to do so or to Rwanda you
could send families with young children
to Rwanda that is we could do and let me
just explain why that matters because
there's a there's a difficult decision
at the heart of this which you're right
to to pick up on but if we didn't do
that then what we would see is people
smuggling gangs preying upon families or
people purporting to be families and
specializing in bringing those people
across the channel in small boats and I
don't want to see that I don't want
children to be at the behest of people
Smugglers I've met children and families
who have just arrived on our Shores
where we've literally saved their lives
at Sea and as a parent that is a
shocking and horrible thing to see and
so by removing families I think we'll
have the deterrent effect that's
required so they stay in France which is
obviously a safe place and is where a
family seeking protection should remain
but could also be sent as you say to
third countries under the scheme how
about unaccompanied children
unaccompanied children will be given a
short bridging leave so they'll remain
in the UK until they turn 18 and then at
that point they will be removed either
back home if their home country is a
safe place or to a safe Third Country
like Rwanda again what we don't want to
see is the UK being exploited by people
smuggling ants who Prey Upon children or
those people who are purporting to be
children that would be wrong what
happens to them in this bridging period
then well they would remain in the UK
and they'd be cared for uh by local
authorities in the way that they are
today for a short period remember that
most of the miners that we receive as a
country today who are unaccompanied are
16 or 17 year old males who are here for
mainly for work in the in the black
economy what we would do is look after
them for that short period appropriately
and you know decently compassionately
but then we would remove them afterwards
because I think the alternative would be
that the people smokers will be bringing
over children and also adults would be
purporting to be children which creates
all sorts of safeguarding risks that we
just don't want as a country I just want
to talk a little bit about
um
the fact that many people would say
there are no safe and legal routes or
few safe and legal routes for people who
are not from
Ukraine from Afghanistan from Hong Kong
where we have this established process
to get into the country they're
desperate this is why they're making the
journey in the first place uh many from
countries where
they clearly have human rights issues
they're not all economic migrants as you
say now I just want to play what Chris
hit and Harris told me on the program on
uh Sunday uh about safe and legal roots
I'm just quite sure there'll be more
safe and legal routes and that's why
um you know and that's why we have them
and you're quite right they've been
proven to work so he told me there will
be more safe and legal routes is that
right are you living here it is the bill
says uh is that we will create a new
safe and legal route as a country and
that will be one which has a set quota
we will consult annually local
authorities to see what capacity they
have in terms of Housing and school
places to support those people
appropriately and then the Home
Secretary of the day will come to
Parliament and seek parliamentary
approval for that and I think that's
quite a grown-up mature way of handling
this situation where we do have a safe
and legal route but it's one which is
rooted in the true capacity of local
authorities so that we don't have people
in hotels or clearly inappropriate
accommodation and we can set that number
at a level that means we can look after
people in the way that you or I on the
British would expect I I would just
having said that take issue with the
premise of the question which is that
the UK is somehow ungenerous oh that's
not that's not what I'm saying well
that's absolutely not one last year I I
didn't say that at all what I'm saying
is that there are safe and legal routes
for people coming from some countries
and no safe and legal routes from other
countries that's not quite true for for
some countries you're right to say the
UK has been incredibly generous like
Ukraine Hong Kong Syria Afghanistan and
quite rightly so to the point that last
year we issued more humanitarian visas
than any year since the end of the
second world war almost half a million
since 2015 but there are already safe
and legal routes from other countries we
have a resettlement scheme where we work
with the UN HCR which is operating in
those countries where there are
conflicts or serious human rights abuses
which people can apply to but but I also
don't think the UK can just offer
support to anyone in any part of the
world it's right that we focus our
finite resources on those places and
people to whom we've got so that's
geographical moral historical obligation
yeah that's the point all countries do
that in the world I think that's that's
completely understandable
um I just want to get your action to
tweet by Gary lineker at the footballer
who's taken issue with the scheme on
moral grounds he said there is no huge
influx we take far fewer refugees than
other major European countries this is
just an immeasurably cruel policy
directed at the most vulnerable people
in language that's not dissimilar to
that used by Germany in the 30s and I'm
out of order
well firstly on the language that he
uses I think that is inflammatory and
wrong you shouldn't throw around
comparisons with the Nazis and 1930s
Germany he should choose his language
carefully just as politicians should do
and I suspect he's been in the public
eye long enough to know exactly the kind
of reaction that he was going to provoke
but on the policy he's also wrong
because unlike Gary lineker I see every
day in my job what the evil people
smuggling gangs are actually doing and
yes
cruel and heartless what he's talking
people are dying as a result of their
activities and the only way to break
their business model is to implement a
policy like so talking about though is
that we take fewer refugees than other
major European countries and actually if
you look at applications made in 2021 uh
per head per 100 000 population you know
we are quite a long way down at the list
aren't we and Germany France Switzerland
Netherlands Spain well it depends how
you how you look at the figures I mean
if you look at the homes for Ukraine
scheme that is that's not that is twice
the size of the French equivalent just
you're just using one example of just
people I think it's like the overall
it's a pretty significant scheme you're
talking about about 150 000.
okay let me let me answer and let me
answer a different way then if you look
at the countries who take people on safe
and legal routes organized by the unhcr
we are the fourth largest recipient of
those individuals of any developed
countries
that overall figures you're looking at
well I'm looking at the countries in
terms of how would you measure a
country's willingness to embrace those
people who are in greatest Eden
is
another major European countries well I
don't think that's correct I mean
obviously they're a countries like
Poland who borders you know that
position within Europe means that
inevitably very large numbers of people
have crossed them they've welcomed them
in a compassionate manner but the
schemes that we have put forward in
recent years are incredibly generous and
compassionate and that will always
continue you're still going to watch
much of the day
yeah of course so well I like watching
Gary lineker I just don't always enjoy
his tweets and think he should choose
his language more carefully okay thank
you very much thank you